le triste décès d'un autre grand
représentants du monde des arts au
québec michel dumont son départ a été
confirmé on vous le rappelle en toute
fin d'après midi il avait 79 ans temps
personnes ont pu prendre la mesure de
son talent au fil des décennies que ce
soit au théâtre ou petit ou grand écran
sa fougue sa passion sa voix son regard
resteront gravés dans bien des mémoires
je vous propose de parler de michel
dumont avec quelqu'un qui l'a côtoyé de
près le comédien normand d'amour un des
premiers d'ailleurs avoir réagi
aujourd'hui publiquement à son décès
bonsoir monsieur d'amour merci d'être là
avec nous les victimes si mes
condoléances dans un tout premier temps
vous l'avez côtoyé de très près comme je
le disais parlez nous un peu de l'homme
vous l'avait qualifié de frère spirituel
aujourd'hui de perdre deux complices
vous vous dites bâti dans le même moule
que michel dumont qui était-il
effectivement la première fois que j'ai
donné à cette expression c'est un
journaliste qui nous interviewait les
deux pour un spectacle s'appelait rien à
voir avec livre signale une des
nombreuses pièces avec lequel j'ai brûlé
les planches avec michel il nous
demandait il m'a demandé à moi ce que
michel est ton genre de père spirituel
je dis non à part est encore vivant
michel c'est mon frère spirituel et ça
nous est restée jusqu'à les derniers
moments où je les ai vus il ya quand
même près de là et puis michel c'est un
homme extrêmement généreux justement
avec qui j'ai fait plein de choses
surtout de jouer avec lui sur cinq comme
à la télé il a été mon père dans yamaska
a été mon père dans le garagiste dont
même c'est moi qui l'avais proposé à un
débours lieu la réalisatrice durenque
garagiste pour qu'il soit mon père parce
que je trouvais que notre notre
complicité ensemble sur scène et que ce
soit sur scène ou sur éclat était très
probante alors c'était je suis en ce
moment crée très très très troublée et
très triste évidemment comme vous pouvez
le constater mais je sais qu'il n'est
pas lié pas parti seul alors ça ça me ça
me réjouit quand même plus de savoir ça
parce que les derniers moments où on
essayé de contacter on n'avait pas
vraiment
de retour
alors je me disais mon dieu qu'est ce
qui se passe mais c'est un homme
extrêmement orgueilleux mais conscient
que évidemment de se voir dépérir comme
seul et n'était pas pour tous quelque
chose qui voulaient qik est ce que ce
soit vu alors je peux comprendre puis
demain son désarroi par rapport à il ya
2 0 en fait la tristesse de bien des
gens l'imaginent aussi je regardais d'un
hommage qui lui avait été rendu chez
duceppe duceppe qui était associé lui
très longtemps duceppe à la tête pendant
près de trente ans du simple même 40 ans
est de 40 ans et sa fille se dévouent
cette entreprise et michel marc bouchard
le décrivait comme étant un être
rassurant eurocks un cheval impétueux
dit béatrice picard un gros nounours se
disait une autre personne qu'il avait
côtoyé jeu il a mené il a eu une
influence unis francine ans sur les gens
qui l'entourent mais sur le théâtre en
général quel était son empreinte quel
sera son legs à cet homme son legs c'est
d'avoir été un homme extrêmement intègre
à tout ce qu'il faisait
il était d'une grande vérité il était
d'une grande spontanéité et c'est là que
j'ai beaucoup appris aussi la façon
d'être sur une scène et la façon d'être
dans la vie ou si il était partout où
j'étais avec lui que ce soit sur les
planches ou dans la vie c'est un immense
honneur de côtoyer cette enveloppe parce
que il me dégager une espèce justement
de ce montant évidemment là c'est michel
dumont mais on le sait qu'au cours des
dernières années il y en a eu plusieurs
de ses grands monuments de ces pans
entiers finalement de l'héritan depuis
près le puy un ennemi c'est l'hécatombe
comment vous le vivez ça mais quand je
me dis souvent je parlais justement
denis bernard aujourd'hui que c'est lui
qui m'a annoncé le décès de michel et
tous les deux on était complètement
dévasté aux loges ce qui reste de porter
le flambeau
désolé désolé ce n'est pas désormais
c'est de porter le flambeau
il doit faire en sorte que la mémoire de
ces gens là vivent encore longtemps
alors on va faire de nous les gens de 50
60 ans pour justement faire en sorte que
ces grandes voix du théâtre puissent
toujours être à fond oui elle sera
entendue est se perpétueront dans le
coeur et dans la tête de tandja
merci beaucoup d'avoir été vous aussi
très généreux dans votre témoignage
aujourd'hui on souhaite nous
condoléances évidemment aux proches et à
la famille de monsieur d'humour bien
gentil à tous merci beaucoup au revoir
au revoir